[Music]
a
La Russia is
[Music]
amazing how much attention has been
placed on Germany's dependency on on
Russia but actually Italy follows a
close second within the EU this is a war
economy so we are suffering and has
affected substantially Italian business
with the sanctions and With the Energy
prices it raises all kinds of questions
about whether Georgia Maloney really
will be able to maintain Italy's support
for Ukraine and a tough stand against
the Russian invasion
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
infondo
product
is
now uh Italy has been caught on the
wrong side of this long-term investment
bet and is having to disentangle itself
um and is finding it quite hard to do
important
after the fall of the Soviet Union Italy
benefited enormously from Russia's
economic recovery and the rise of a
wealthy upper middle class in particular
who seemed to consume Italian Goods in
vast quantities
the fact that we had a loss of business
because of the sanctions is as affected
the public opinion and the other effort
is inflation and then there is a big
discussion about inflation but it's
clear that this inflation in Europe is
not demand led the supply-led and the
reason why we have an increase in prices
is very much related to increase in
Energy prices which is a consequence of
the war in Ukraine because obviously we
had to re-assess or completely our
energy sources and like move them from
Russia to anywhere else including the us
because now the US is one of the major
provider of energy for Europe and for
Italy Italy was the fourth Russian
export destination up until 2021 and
clearly Italy's energy dependence with
Russia has been a big theme throughout
the past 20 years 40 percent of Italy's
gas and most of its coal came from
Russia up until the war broke out and a
certain percentage of the oil and the
crude that Italy uses as well Italy also
a kind of Diversified the energy Supply
by going to Northern Africa and you know
making deals with interesting countries
like Algeria or Libya which is
particularly demographic at the moment
but this has had a huge impact on
Italian finances and as a huge import on
the Italian on Italian families
is
foreign
[Music]
the sanctions regime from the West was
incredibly quick stealthy and Powerful
you were a business operating in Russia
with with Russian customers you probably
used one of the western Banks quickly
those relationships were closed and you
know a lot of these business people had
to look for elsewhere to have their
banking services even if the war is
ongoing and Russia has been sanctioned
by the EU there are companies that
continue doing business with Russia
there are Italian banks that have not
shut down their operations in Russia
unicredit's been in Russia since 2005 at
the outbreak of the war it had about two
million customers 70 branches and about
3 500 staff so a pretty big presence in
Russia among the International Banks it
was among the top three with the biggest
exposure in Russia Andrea Rochelle the
CEO of unicredit has consistently said
he doesn't want to leave money on the
table he doesn't want to send actually
hand over their Russian business to
Putin's allies and and to the Kremlin
the the prospect of selling the business
has become much much harder in the last
six months because the Kremlin and
Vladimir Putin have actually intervened
to basically rubber stamp any sale of a
Western Bank in Russia and that makes it
much harder because you're essentially
having to sell to people who are very
closely tied to the Kremlin that's not
something that unicredit want to do and
also really the Kremlin would be
dictating the terms of those sales and
would be demanding much lower prices
than what the businesses are actually
worth at a European banking level the
ECB has openly called on uni credit and
other banks with big Russian presence to
really exit as swiftly as they can
they've been private conversations as
well so it's in a very tricky position
playing this big geopolitical tensions
and it's it's very much been caught in
the middle of all those
[Music]
foreign
is composed by three parties you have
brothers
which is led by Meloni Georgia Maloney
and she's also the Prime Minister and
the first female prime minister in
Italian History she got 26 percent of
the votes so she is leading the
Coalition by all means the junior
Partners in this government Coalition
are on one side the city of Berlusconi
who is in his 80s and is the leader of
for Sedalia and on the other side of the
Coalition you have Mateo salvini who is
actually the leader of the league La
Liga they have not enough votes even put
together to represent a credible
alternative to Maloney
salvini is coming forward to once again
make the case that the Western strategy
of sanctions against Russia and
isolating Russia isn't working Mateo
salvini has made no secret of his
admiration for Putin he's been filmed
wearing Putin t-shirts in red square and
he wore Putin t-shirts in the EU
Parliament and so he is really what some
would described as a Putin fanboy
[Music]
foreign
Political Animals they know it so they
sense it they say that there is a
possibility of getting part of the
electorate on
and in the war in Ukraine and in this
actions towards Putin and so on you can
see it's also a symbiotic relationship
where a lot of these right-wing parties
they know that Russia is out there and
might be willing to help them Putin has
become an icon of this world these days
many voters of the league or brothers of
Italy they actually like Putin they like
him personally
movement the fact that they say that
they are not neo-fascists or
post-fascists of the never been fascists
they have to say it because there is
still a clause in the Italian
Constitution which is anti-fascism but
they actually were fascists particularly
Miss Maloney because she was a member of
MSI which is
party what has been particularly
interesting in the last decade or so is
how Russia has really latched on to the
idea of right-wing populist politics in
Europe as a very powerful lever of
influence Russia really wants to D
stabilize the center ground of politics
in Europe and to remove from Power all
of those stable political Centrist
governments that are better positioned
to stand up to Russia Putin's United
Russia party forged political links with
all kinds of actors in different parts
of the Italian political Spectrum so on
one hand we have salvini the leader of
the league who was an unabashed Putin
admirer but we also Elsewhere on the
political Spectrum have the five-star
party which also is believed or
suspected to have person-to-person ties
with key people in Russia Georgia
Maloney's government is going to be
probably permanently embarrassed by some
of the instincts of of her Coalition
Partners operations
foreign
these two men have always liked each
other there's been a close bond between
the two but he has always had a
Fascination for the Soviets for Russia
and for Vladimir Putin they've gone on
holiday together reportedly and they've
always been quite friendly and this has
also translated into closer business
ties and economic ties between the two
countries
Putin first met at the G7 in Genoa there
was an immediate bond between the two
and after that meeting in 2001 there
were many phone calls you have to
imagine in 2003 the war in chechnya when
reporters asked Berlusconi to comment
the atrocities committed by the Russians
that were well documented and well-known
Berlusconi said please let's not spread
Legends is
foreign
she imagined himself and Italy as this
bridge that was gonna Usher a once
isolated Vladimir Putin and Russia into
the family of the West he had all kinds
of schemes
when he was talking to Putin was it on
behalf of the Republic of Italy or was
it himself
um where did the one Brothers corny
begin when did the other one end it was
never really clear Russian oligarchs saw
Italy as a relatively welcoming place
where they could invest many major
oligarchs bought large industrial Assets
in Italy they bought mansions and
Beachside Holiday Homes and of course
all of this was facilitated by the great
relationship between Italy's Prime
Minister Silvio Berlusconi and Russia's
Vladimir Putin we are important as a
country for Russia because we we are
perceived and in at least in part we are
a weak link within the European Union
even in the process for example of the
the the sanctioning the the Russian
oligarchs or the voting motions in the
EU Parliament after World War II Italy
had the largest communist party in
Western Europe many of the partisans
that fought against Mussolini and
fascism and on the side of the Allies
were actually Communists they were
members of the Communist Party of Italy
a huge party many millions of Italians
uh pledging Legends to Moscow and to the
Communist cause and that's of course
hugely important in the Strategic
equation Giorgio Maloney the leader of
Brothers of Italy the far-right party
post-fascist party has had pro-russian
sympathies in the past but at this
moment she has taken a pretty Firm
Stance and I think is in a way cleverly
created a narrative about how a party
like hers should be supporting Ukraine
this is a country struggling for
National survival and as a nationalist
party or leader of a nationalist party
she can see the value in that Village
yeah
she has been a very strong supporter of
the U.S of the Republican party and now
she knows that in order to stay in
Powers she cannot push anti-eu or
anti-nato rhetorics
we are on the side of international law
we are on the side of freedom and indeed
we are on the side of a proud nation
that is teaching the world what it means
to fight for freedom
partners and certainly Kiev should
probably rest reasonably assured that
Italy will not deviate massively from
this path the issue in Italy is public
opinion it's clearly uh the softest in
this war although there is a majority in
favor of support for Ukraine it's the
narrowest majority that there is in the
EU and Italians are also more likely
than other European countries to pin
blame on Kiev or even on NATO and the
West for this conflict this is so
relevant if you have elections however
if it becomes less relevant if you do
not have elections and again even if the
we did have elections until when the
International Coalition is so much
favorable to intervention in Ukraine
even for an Italian government who is
against it will be almost impossible to
pull off
foreign
[Music]
correndo
foreign
[Music]